berlin s'apprête à célébrer la chute du
mur il ya dix ans le 9 novembre 89
l'histoire s'est brusquement accéléré le
rideau de fer est tombé aujourd'hui il
reste quelques rares vestiges du mur qui
séparait la ville en deux mémona
hintermann et robin ce bull ont retrouvé
un ancien officier de la stasi qui avait
participé à sa construction reportage
novembre 99 cdja le mur de berlin qu'on
reconstruit le mur c'est tout ce qu'il
en reste quelques centaines de mètres à
préserver d'urgence contre elle une
arrière à led corps lui ne peut pas
l'oublier raconté le mur c'est le devoir
que ce cartographe citoyens de l'ex rda
s'est fixé et pourtant
ici à cet endroit précis des buts 61 je
reçois l'ordre de tracer une ligne dans
mon esprit ça va nous protéger des
criminels de loin
l'endroit devient célèbre sous le nom de
checkpoint charlie la frontière entre
deux mondes le temps passe et le caporal
de la stasi fait son chemin dans la
hiérarchie de la police secrète il jure
aujourd'hui avoir ouvert les yeux bien
avant la chute du mur en novembre 89 il
revient ce ce qu'il appelle les lieux du
crime
je suis revenu au poste-frontière
j'ai récupéré ceci j'ai apposé un
dernier coup de tampon comme un symbole
exactement au même endroit de la ligne
tracée en ligne vers son passé et je me
suis dit ici ou ça prend fin
ce mirador doit rester le symbole du
totalitarisme
de la dictature
alors que tout semblait
lui faut qu'ils restent pas provoqué il
faut que les gens se posent la question
mais qu'est ce qui s'est donc passé ici
traître pour les un criminel pour les
autres la rda c'était sa cause il ne la
renie pas clairement pour expliquer la
différence entre lui et un héros comme
borat schumann soldat de 19 ans qui fuit
à l'ouest ils réclament ce qu'il appelle
le droit à la gym
moi non je n'ai pas à m'excuser pour ce
que j'ai fait mais je dois chercher à
tirer les leçons de métro
est il coupable doit-il payer oui et non
répondent ces jeunes allemands de
l'ouest et de l'est il préfère le
laisser seul face à sa conscience mais
la justice allemande elle n'a pas fini
de lui demander des côtes malgré tout
les allemands ne veulent pas perdre trop
de temps règlement de compte il préfère
regarder l'avenir sachant qu'il leur
faudra bien plus de dix ans encore avant
de pouvoir recoller vraiment les deux
morceaux de l'allemagne